what yeah they're Muppets they're not
house puppets they're Muppets Muppets
I thought Muppets was not what they are
it's the Henson Company though so I mean
it's all their designs and it's all
there is that what Sesame Street tried
suing them they called them puppets if
they were Muppets they would have called
them Muppets John okay I assumed BAM
movie fights I went around one how
what's round two hi guys i'm gregory
alba john is my name we watched a happy
time Merkers and now we're gonna do a
movie review are you excited
mildly right anywho before we go into
this a couple of mentions we are leaving
for Mexico August 23rd to the 25th
courtesy of Warner Brothers so if
anything big drops and we don't cover it
just be patient
maybe when we get back secondly over at
patreon we do full-length TV show
reactions and weekly Q&A s and offer a
bunch of other goodies why don't you
have a page from the day shout out to a
man named Austin Moore this video fits
perfectly to shut this guy out because
Austin Moore is working on a couple of
Star Wars projects and you know Muppets
Star Wars it's all like no I mean he's
working a lot with a lot of different
designs and stop-motion and that goes
hand in hand with puppeteering in some
ways when you're making a film does it
I'm trying to have it make sense for you
author and half just go check out his
channel there's a link in the
description box damn it just go check it
out Austin I love you can't wait for
that Star Wars fan film to come out
I don't know behind-the-scenes stuff
guys working a lot of projects hooker
doing well we're una shadow let's talk
about the happy time murders alright so
in this movie there's a world it's a
universe okay and in this world there
are puppets and humans and puppets are
rather segregated you know they're
looked down upon
so that's the world okay but the main
character is Phil Phillips a blue
looking Muppet who is a PI and he was a
former detective and there was a show
that along
in the 90s that start Elizabeth Banks
playing someone else and a bunch of
other Muppet characters and now a lot of
the Muppet cast of that show is being
killed off Phil Phillips was linked to
some of the cast members in some ways
now he has to partner up with his former
partner and played by Melissa McCarthy
to go solve this case this is a dark
gritty crime thriller so if you guys saw
the trailer for this you would know that
this is a hard-r muppet film it really
is yeah one thing I can assure you of is
the trailer is in no way misleading no
you get a hundred percent what you
expect you get a thousand percent yeah
what you'd expect this movie doesn't
strive to be anything more than just a
funny movie that's an r-rated Muppet
like film yeah this isn't striving to be
anything more than that it's a novelty I
think that any opinion of any movie is
obviously subjective and I think if
there's a genre that is very subjective
it is comedy comedy to me is the most
subjective and in the winner for Best
Motion Picture comedy the Martian that
is just my subjective opinion on genres
this movie I had noticed that when we
were in the theater I'd say a big bulk
of the theater was laughing consistently
throughout the movie I was sitting next
to John and I'd say John was laughing
more than I was laughing at the movie
I'll say I enjoyed it it was still
entertaining throughout there's a lot of
jokes in this movie here and I didn't
crack up through most of the movie but
there were a couple of really good
laughs that I did have that were coming
very intermittently for me but overall
to enjoy the film John what's your take
yeah ultimately like I said I kind of
got everything that I expected it's
super offensive in the most inoffensive
way possible so you know if you like
this kind of comedy and if you like the
Muppet world in general I think you'd
appreciate it but I also don't think
that it's anything particularly
groundbreaking or special or beyond a
novelty because if you remove the puppet
aspect of the movie then you just kind
of have a standard you know cop buddy
cop yeah yeah a lot of the jokes rely on
the fact that
they are puppets now so good because if
you take away the puppets for majority
of these jokes I think that it's
wouldn't be funny it would just be like
a weird version of Starsky and Hutch or
something yeah if you watch the trailer
and if you really like the trailer odds
are you're gonna like the movie and we
like the trailer so I am the I'd say I
like the movie I don't love this movie
one thing I did bring up in our review
for that trailer was this part it's
shocking if you're not like prepared for
like a hard-r Muppets but the actual
viewing experience though a big part of
the effect of this trailer was the
surprise value of that I'm wondering if
once this process is with someone like
me and then I go watch this movie will
it still actually be funny and
surprising you know that's it's pretty
quick you settle into this world of oh
this is just hard or vulgar
throughout that joke that what there's
like the one nucleus of a joke they use
that word I'm not sure let's find out
which is their Muppets it but it's hard
are that's kind of the crux of the whole
movie and that tickles you you know if
seeing a bunch of silly spray Muppet
baby juice is funny to you instead of
snorting drugs they snort sugar yeah
those movies were kind of the charms are
in the little details of the world and
the funny ways that this hybrid puppet
human world resembles our own in silly
ways yeah to me I find that stuff more
amusing like okay the juice that's silly
string the drugs is sugar it was more of
like the dialogue that I would get kind
of like okay I mean don't get me wrong I
said as a subjective opinion because
most of the theater was laughing at
these jokes where a lot of time I'd be
there going okay I get it uh this pup is
offered to give a fellatio yeah that's
funny because it's a puppet offering to
yeah but if a human said it it just
wouldn't be funny yeah and we've already
seen that canto time Xena I feel
you hit the nail with the word amusing
like the the main flavor I left this
movie with was it's amusing for me it's
not like a great comedy necessarily the
Martian but I did find it thoroughly
amusing there's a lot of fun
light-hearted stuff going on and a lot
of imaginative little flourishes yeah a
lot of it feels very improvised and I
think when you watch what's going on
during the credits like honestly the
credits made me appreciate the movie
it's really easy to appreciate the
craftsmanship because it is a very
smooth blend of puppet and human life
you know and you see in the credits that
you know they had to have a lot of
actors in green-screen outfits moving
the puppets around because there were
some shots so I was like how they do
that so I was impressed with that on a
technical scale I found it that it could
be it's might seem like a weird
criticism that it was kind of totally
confusing to me at times there's two
things I can't flash in my mind Judd
Apatow in the movie bright yeah going
back with I say Judd Apatow because he
knows how to make horror movies that
also have a level of heart and there are
certain plot points that occur in this
movie and this movie is really all about
just getting the laughs and I'm well
aware of that but there are plot points
that occur in this movie where I'm like
this this could be your time to have
more heart especially if you're using
the Muppets as your I know like the joke
is that it's Muppets doing hard art but
I really felt like this would have
worked a little better if it honed in
more on its heart as well mm-hmm yeah I
agree with you I mean I do think that it
had some yeah anymore to me the best
jokes in this movie were when it was
just character driven dialogue banter
that was going on I find that usually in
a comedy like this this stuff I
appreciate the most yeah the stuff
that's clever on its own and yeah rely
on a gimmick it doesn't rely on the on
the gimmick of it's a puppets aid hard
to see when they make fun of certain
things in this movie I won't give away
the the actual jokes of course but like
when cops break into
house and they have to like whisper
stuff to each other it's like a really
funny bit there yeah just about cop
movies in general yeah we're just even
just witty banter moments those are the
things they stick and Melissa McCarthy
to me is the funniest one in this film I
kind of love when she plays cops to be
honest like yeah like he really good
yeah yeah yeah I think Melissa McCarthy
is hilarious in this film yeah she
easily got the biggest laughs and she's
really good and her like she really
commits to the interaction with the
puppets yeah like I think with that what
heard Maya Rudolph to actually my
Rudolph is great he's not doesn't have
anywhere near as much screen time but
when she's there it's really cool and
plus my rudolph and melissa mccarthy get
a decent amount of screen time together
and that was a nice little bridesmaids
reunion in some way for me personally
yeah watching it they play off each
other really well
yeah and what they interact with the
puppets they they really are interacting
with them like their characters yeah and
I feel like that's this movies perhaps
strongest asset is that it is funny and
wacky and zany but everybody commits
just enough to sell it yeah I don't feel
like it's so serious that you're like
what's going on here but it is so light
that nothing matters it's just enough to
be an innocuous ly good time I feel like
I guess my only real issue with it is I
felt like it could have used a lot more
actual clever jokes in the movie a bit
more cleverness and a bit more heart
could have elevated this into something
truly lovable and memorable yeah
beyond just being kind of a cartoon yeah
it's a very juvenile humor and I think
when you watch the trailer
all I think that if you watch the
trailer and you like the trailer you're
gonna get what you want when you watch
the movie and like I said comedy is
subjective so I walked out going I liked
it I enjoyed it it's alright John liked
it a little more than me I imagine and
then there's a lot of people in theater
who seem like they loved it so yeah I
want I think partly to it probably has
to do with how you feel about Muppets in
general I know a lot of people grew up
yeah muffets and also things like
Fraggle Rock and meet the Feebles and
you know meet the Feebles is really
raunchy and you know be accidental that
so depending on how you feel about all
those things you might walk out with an
actual attachment to this for me it was
like I haven't seen a muppet thing in a
very long time like I've I know the
Muppets a bit yeah you know I grew up
with Sesame Street and things like that
but I'm not like mister Muppets so yeah
this was just kind of like a fun change
of pace more than anything but I also
had a fine time I enjoyed myself you
know overall I think it succeeds where
who wants to yeah yeah it does exactly
what it wants to do and if that's for
you then it's free yeah and if it's not
for you I don't really know what else
you can kind of expect of this movie
because not trying to accomplish
anything comes over all I get a 3 out of
5 yeah sounds about fair alright guys
well what beloved children's type of
category would you like to see a hard
our version of personally I'd like to
see a hard our version of Deadpool yeah
we need that we are so limited I think
r-rated my little pony could be good you
know cuz that mythology is really
expanded and to take you know full
control dude of those horses no one at
it would just be appropriate hey do what
we do video hey so we're youtubers and
we're gonna say some stuff to you that
you've probably never heard in the video
before you can subscribe ring or click
the notification bell I know no it's
Wheatley right and check us out on
patreon what were the first ones ever
over there we got a bunch of stuff love
to have your support
third movie fight is gonna be all over
us send into Valhalla six extra trivia
filled back
[Music]